art directors are a strange and
wonderful breed while some of them are
duplicating ancient Rome in Arizona
others are reconstructing old Arizona
and Rome to present the Award for art
direction here two of Hollywood's most
decorative people miss Shirley Jones and
mr. Rock Hudson
surely I'd like to ask you something
no mediums movies or television which do
you prefer
well I like movies much better what well
because you want an Oxford no no because
you don't have to change the color well
I prefer television Wow
because there's so many good movies on
read the nominations Rock nominees for
the best achievement in art direction
are John Ruskin and Edward career for
Camelot set decoration by John W Brown
Marielle Kyary Jack Martin Smith and Ed
graves for dr. Dolittle set decoration
by Walter M Scott and Stuart a Rhys
Robert Klatte worthy for guess who's
coming to dinner set decoration by Frank
Tuttle renzo man Giardino John the Cure
Evelyn Webb and Giuseppe Mariani for
Taming of the Shrew set decoration by
Dario Simoni and Luigi Java C alexander
Golitsyn and George a web for Thoroughly
Modern Millie set decoration by Howard
Bristol surely you did the others thank
you the winners are John Truscott and
Edward Carrere for Camelot and for set
decoration john w bra
unfortunately mr. Korea isn't here
tonight he's making a picture in Mexico
so on his behalf I would like to say
thank you and for myself thank you again
thank you ladies and gentlemen of the
Academy for honoring me with this award
and I would also like to thank the
technicians and craftsmen at one of our
seven art studios whose artistic
achievements and excellent workmanship
enabled me to get this honor thank you